Thinking about putting together a
great home cocktail bar?
Just interested in this fascinating,
highly expressive subculture?
Reason's Features editor Peter
Suderman talks with Jacob Grier,
a craft cocktail bartender and
writer based in Portland, Oregon.
Grier is a Reason contributor and
co-author with Brett Adams
of the new book "Raising the Bar:
A Bottle by Bottle Guide
to Mixing Masterful Cocktails
at Home." Suderman speaks with Grier
about the pleasures of making
cocktails the way the Internet and
the pandemic have changed home
bartending and what lessons
alcohol prohibition still
has for public policy today.
Jacob, thank you so much for joining
us.
Peter, thanks for having me on and
great to see you.
It's great to see you, too man.
So Jacob and I are old friends and
it's we're also both cocktail
enthusiasts.
Before we get to the book, I
actually just want to ask you.
This is this is a book that
has a lot of cocktail recipes.
And it's obviously the product
of it's obviously the product
of great passion.
You are somebody who really likes
cocktails. So what
makes a great cocktail?
Like, why are they so wonderful?
Oh, for me, it's all about just
like the complexity and the balance
of it and the ability to take
so many different flavors and
integrate them into something that's
bigger than all the different parts.
You know, when you think about what
goes into some of the bottles that
we have on our shelves when we're
mixing a cocktail, you know, if it's
a whiskey, you know, that might have
been like ten or 12 years sitting in
an oak barrels
getting better. If it's an Amaro, it
might be 30 different herbs.
If it stretches, it might be 130
different herbs.
So you get the product of
all this incredibly hard work and
complexity that's gotten put
into bottles for us.
And then in a matter of a minute, we
can make ourselves something
incredible at home with all these
different layers to taste, which I
think is really cool. And it's hard
that you can't really do that with
anything else, like cooking,
you know, to get that kind of
complexity out of cooking is going
to take you a lot of time and
you know, other things. You just
want the purity of it.
Like with coffee, I don't really mix
coffee. I just want to taste the
being as it's made it.
With cocktails, you can have all
this fun taking incredible products
and making something unique with it.
Yeah, I love I love cocktails
because they have character, right?
Like each one of them is a
distinctive personality.
And you can tweak that personality
in the glass. So let's let's get to
the book now.
Tell us, why should we buy this
book? What's it about and
why should people want to make
cocktails at home?
I mean, shouldn't we just go to a
bar and pay $16 for
somebody to do this for us?
Well, if you can find a really good
$16 cocktail, now, you're you're
ahead of the curve.
The inflation it's come
for it's come for our drink.
It has. Yeah. And as someone who
bartenders, I obviously encourage
people to do that and to go out and
buy drinks.
But this book, even though it's
written with the home bartender in
mind, it really is made for anyone.
No matter what your experience
level. There's more than 200 recipes
in here.
So unless you've been hacking into
my computer and in reading
those in advance, there's going to
be something new for you in it.
But the main idea of the book is
we wanted to get past the
frustration that I have and
a lot of people have with
contemporary cocktail books
where like Peter, you and I both
have huge collections of booze at
home. A little too much, to
be honest.
And, you know, we want to never
enough. Never enough.
Yeah. I'm at the point where I'm
just like, I'm targeting bottles for
elimination. Like, I'm going to make
cocktails with this bottle.
And so it's gone.
But even with that, with this
massive amount of liquor at home,
I would often get a new cocktail
book. I'd be really excited and
like, I want to come home and peruse
this and find a recipe to make
and there's nothing I can make.
And my collection is ridiculous.
So if I can't make it, then the
ordinary reader definitely can't
make it.
And so what my co-author and I,
Brett Adams, he and I got
together and we kind of mapped out
this idea of how to make a
cocktail book where that would never
happen.
And so what we decided
was we have a pretty basic pantry of
ingredients, a few different
bitters, sirups, citrus,
easy things to keep around the house
and then with.
Nonalcoholic ingredients.
Nonalcoholic.
Yeah. And then for the, for the
booze we would take it one bottle at
a time. So with the first chapter,
literally all we do is say, hey, go
get a bottle of bourbon.
We're going to tell you about
bourbon. And then we're going to
give you nine recipes
that all you need is that bourbon to
make what's in the pantry.
And then we just take you through
the book to up to 25 bottles
where we just add a new bottle to
your collection and say, here's what
it is, and now here's what you can
make now that you've added this to
your bar. And so, you know, the
first few chapters, the cocktails
are all pretty simple but good and
varied in styles.
And then as you progressed through
and you keep adding a new bottle to
your bar, you've got a ton
of different drinks you can make and
the drinks get more complicated as
you go.
So it's a one bottle bar and then a
two bottle bar and then a three
bottle bar.